la Corée du Sud et le Japon tue des
surfroies de la nuit dernière alors que
les autorités de ces deux pays ont
craint une attaque aux missiles de la
Corée du Nord c'est où la même donnée
l'ordre d'évacuer certains sites mais il
ne s'agissait que du lancement raté
d'une fusée devant maître sur orbite un
satellite militaire Pione a reconnu que
la fusée s'était abîmée en mer Rouge
il y a jamais de problème moi c'est ce
que j'ai appris de mon papa pas de
solution que des problèmes tu vois
pas de problème que des solutions pardon
excuse-moi voilà c'est ça je dis
n'importe quoi moi aussi je suis dans
l'émotion là 12 millions c'est notre
chiffre du jour et c'est le nombre de
fumeurs en France un tiers des adultes
déclarent fumer selon santé publique
France après une baisse d'une ampleur
inédite entre 2016 et 2019 le tabagisme
c'est stabilisé en France donc rappelons
que fumée tue 75000 décès par an sont
liés au tabac soit 13% des décès il y a
un type qui est avec un juge
d'instruction on se doute bien qu'il est
peut-être pour ça arrêtez de fumer parce
que là vous êtes au bord du précipice et
on ne sait pas on se dit on se dit que
vous allez faire un grand pas en avant
et on ne sait pas qui est tué et ça vous
le connaissez pas la chambre blanche
oh non mais faites attention quand même
l'arrêt du tabac ah ouais franchement où
est-ce que vous avez bu
euh
[Musique]
je suis dans la les deux copines sont
très en forme elles espèrent bien
continuer leur virer
[Musique]
alors déjà je ne sais pas si vous portez
encore une montre au poignet qui fait
tic tac parce qu'avec les smartphones on
a tous l'horloge dans notre poche donc
premier
[Rires]
[Musique]
même si les deux mamies ne sont pas
agressives les policiers ne peuvent pas
les laisser dans leur état dans les rues
il faut que quelqu'un les surveille pour
leur sécurité
vous avez la famille pas loin là
c'est parce qu'elle raconte qui nous
parle avec moi qui me passionne c'est
une question de principe de quitter
j'ai répété exactement ce que vous aviez
dit 2 secondes plus tôt pour feuilleter
mais souffler dans un éthylotest ne
semble plus à leur porter
non mais pas sur moi dans le machin
[Musique]
impossible de souffler cette jeune femme
que vous voyez qui est en train de se
déchaîner c'est une interprète en langue
des signes qui est en train de traduire
la performance pour pour des
malentendants pour qu'ils puissent
profiter aussi du concert de Bruce
Springsteen alors forcément bah moi j'ai
eu envie de la retrouver attends je
propose qu'on écoute un petit peu quand
même parce que ça
[Musique]
ça donne la pêche
c'est magnifique les amis 4000 euros à
gagner 4000 euros quand je vous avais 5
minutes 5 minutes que vous soyez dans
votre canapé ou votre voiture et bien
vous composez le 32 10 centimes d'euros
la minute ou alors par SMS envoyé RTL ou
74900 75 centimes d'euros par SMS 4 SMS
max merci bonne chance 5 minutes top
merci de conseiller de le faire en
voiture Hervé Pujol en cas d'accident
bien sûr si vous n'êtes pas assuré par
la suite vous nous appellerez et nous
vous aiderons une infraction au code de
la route qui ne plaît pas du tout alors
passager
[Musique]
dans le moteur tourne rouge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et alors quand vous étiez en uniforme de
pompier vous avez dragué pas mal bah
disons que quand j'étais pompier j'avais
une petite amie à l'époque qui a
travaillé au SAMU et
ça sent le fantasme de l'uniforme cette
histoire et elle m'a avoué avoir un
fantasme donc moi étant gentil et
généreux bien sûr
alors j'ai donc accepté de réaliser son
fantasme
dans un camion dans le camion de pompier
Mohamed hawach échappe à la prison le
pilier du 15 de France en rugby de
Montpellier également été condamné à un
an de prison ferme pour violence
conjugale hier mais sans mandat de dépôt
lui permettant donc de ressortir libre
du tribunal lui qui avait frappé sa
femme en centre ville en plein
centre-ville de Montpellier c'était
vendredi parce qu'il l'avait surpris en
train de fumer voilà son explication
j'avoue qu'il manquait que la sirène
mais on a quand même eu le gyrophare en
plein ébat elle a actionné le
sans faire exprès
la devise c'est courage et dévouement ça
va vous avez fait preuve de ça donc moi
ce que je tiens à dire c'est que elle
est bien pensant
culturel de gauche littéraire bien
souvent on ferme les yeux sur ce genre
de situation on a pas mal d'histoires de
maltraitance des femmes dans ces milieux
là en revanche dans le monde du rugby
c'est carré un mec ça déconne pas ça
tape pas sur une femme la métamorphose
est spectaculaire une moustache en moins
et vous oubliez qu'Antoine d'hier et
celui qui a fait Zemmour pendant toute
la campagne présidentielle et oui c'est
toujours Antoine Diers bonjour Olivier
Antoine dire ce on l'avait laissé avec
Éric Zemmour il faisait partie de
l'équipe et puis finalement visiblement
il y a eu rupture